it was unclear at first what had
happened but now it seems for certain
the hackers are holding the foreign
exchange company Travelex to ransom if
you visit a company's website today
you'll be greeted with this message
which claims planned maintenance is the
cause of the temporary outage the
currency operators sites have been down
since New Year's Eve when cyber
criminals penetrated its network but
only today details are now emerging of a
ransomware attack how many percent has
to be ransomware
Rob Shapland is an ethical hacker who is
paid by big businesses to hack their
systems ransomware is a type of virus
that gets onto a computer system usually
via someone opening up an email
attachment that's malicious now that
means in the case of Travelex they can't
get their files back and they're asked
for a ransom payment that's usually Ana
crypto currency like Bitcoin and in this
case they've asked for three million
dollars the incident has also affected
other companies whose travel many sites
are provided by traveling traveling says
that is working with the authorities to
try and regain control of its systems
the met cybercrime team and now leading
the investigation to try and catch those
responsible for crippling the company's
networks some customers are concerned
about what's happened it's just
appalling it's left me a very bad taste
in her mouth
should I get my money back in full which
I'm hoping to do and should my date and
not be compromised which I open it's not
I won't ever be using this organisation
ever again there was a similar attack
into NHS services across England in
Scotland in 2017 when hackers caused
large-scale disruption to hospital and
at GP appointments
according to cyber experts there were
still some companies who have not
implemented measures to improve their
security it's very concerning this is
the basics of computer security really
keeping your systems up to date and not
pointed on to the internet with really
outdated systems is one of the most
basic tenets of computer security so yes
it is worrying that a company as large
as Travelex isn't doing those basics the
financial cost of this attack for travel
X could be unprecedented if customers
details are leaked by hackers the
company could be faced with a maximum
fine of 4 percent of its global turnover
no Philips skinnies